we have another entrance into the 2020
Democratic primary it is democratic
California senator Kamala Harris I was
going to play her announcement video Pat
but let's skip it since we're a little
low on time also announcing in the last
few days was senator Kirsten Gillibrand
from New York I think she has no shot
she didn't make a formal formal
announcement I think she announced that
an announcement is coming sort of like
an exploratory type announcement Kamala
Harris I think has much more of a shot
than Kirsten Gillibrand I loved seeing
Kamala Harris questioned all sorts of
clowns in Senate hearings she has the
right ideas on many issues before doing
a deep dive on her at some point in the
future I will mention two areas of
concern for me
number one we still don't have a good
explanation about why Kamala Harris
didn't prosecute one West Bank for their
foreclosure violations back in 2013 when
she was the Attorney General of
California that was current Treasury
secretary Stephen my Newton's former
bank a very strange statement was put
out not really explaining why there was
no prosecution not really explaining
what degree of involvement she had with
that decision it's a very big question
mark for me and it kind of relates to
more general concerns over Harris
related to her ties to finance and Wall
Street
she's also against police wearing body
cameras and I just don't agree with her
on that issue but big picture she has a
lot of the right ideas and her path to
victory could depend on California
moving up their primary California her
home state has moved up their primary in
the process which could help Kamala
Harris at the same time California
awards their delegates proportionately
based on primary results so unless she
has like just some massive massive
blowout win in California it's not going
to be likely that it would make her the
clear favorite in the Democratic primary
big identity primary so far for women we
have Elizabeth Warren Tulsi Gabbard
Kirsten Gillibrand and now Kamala Harris
we have a
black woman in Kamala Harris we have a
Hispanic man in who Leon Castro we have
a Hindu woman in Tulsi Gabbard and as
much as I don't want it to identity is
no doubt going to figure hugely into the
calculations that are going to be made
and I have a real concern that it's
going to degrade the primary process and
kind of just get in the way of picking
the person with the right positions and
who's most set to lead when it comes to
the end of the of the line and I hope
I'm wrong about that we'll start to see
very shortly it's only January and the
field is getting very very full there's
an upside to that lots of people to
choose from there's a downside to that
which is just because Republicans had 17
people in 2016 and a long shot ended up
winning and becoming the president
doesn't guarantee that Democrats can
have just as much success with that
style so we'll see and we'll continue
coverage of that